the former site of Japan's embassy is
often the focal point for protests
against Japan after the removal of South
Korea from Tokyo's list of preferential
trade partners this protest was
especially passionate
this is them declaring economic war and
firing the first shot my heart goes out
to the Japanese to have politicians who
act like this
it's a deepening dispute born out of
decades old animosities supported by
those old enough to have experienced
Japanese colonial occupation in the last
century along with young people born in
this century many South Koreans have
been boycotting anything Japanese
avoiding holidays to the country causing
Airlines to cancel flights refusing to
buy Japanese goods helped in this
tech-savvy society by apps that tell you
instantly which goods to avoid at
government level the mood is palpable
from the frosty like this recent meeting
between foreign ministers to the heated
this exchange between Japan's foreign
minister and the South Korean envoy it
will retaliate by taking Japan of its
list of preferential trade partners as
this dispute deepens with the leaders of
the two countries
unwilling or unable to back down japan's
Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a wants to see
his country become more assertive in
dealings with its neighbors and the
trade restrictions against South Korea
are popular at home his counterpart moon
jae-in of south korea was carried into
the presidency on a wave of people power
popularity after the forced resignation
and impeachment of his predecessor south
koreans change their government so
there's a heightened sense of pride that
they are shaping their democracy and an
awakened democracy can't take Japan's
recent actions sitting down that's why
we're seeing this expression of anger
the economies of both countries are
likely to be harmed in this tit-for-tat
wrangle but for now settling old scores
seems an irresistible force
Rob McBride al Jazeera Seoul